ob man es für das einzig wahre geld hält
oder es lediglich als lebloses metall
erachtet gold zieht den menschen seit
6000 jahren in seinen bann
ich bin grant williams im ersten teil
dieser reise betrachteten wir die
geschichte des goldes und wie es seit
jahrtausenden herz und verstand des
menschen erobert sie erfuhren wie sich
der goldabbau über die jahrhunderte
veränderte und wie komplex die
weiterverarbeitung von gold ist auch
besuchten wir als erstes filmteam den
geheimsten gold tresor der welt wir
beleuchteten die geschichte des
goldstandards und wie ein präsident 1971
entschied das gold fenster zu schließen
was die welt tiefgreifend verändert
wichtiger noch wir gründeten warum gold
zu geld wurde und es immer noch ist
im zweiten teil der reise beleuchten wir
wie gold im östlichen und westlichen
kulturen unterschiedlich wahrgenommen
wird
wir erläutern den unterschied zwischen
gold etf s und dem metall selbst und
warum der goldpreis nicht der preis von
gold ist die alles entscheidende frage
ist zudem ist der goldpreis manipuliert
und wenn ja von wem
zuletzt geht es um die zukunft des
goldes welche rolle spielen crypto
währungen ist der bitcoin das neue gold
oder doch nur eine weitere todgeweihte
alternative zum einzigen zeitlosen geld
[Musik]
obwohl es seit jahrtausenden als währung
und wertspeicher dient reicht die
beziehung des menschen zu gold viel
weiter sein stellenwert in der
geschichte geht weit über münzen barren
und schmuck hinaus zu beginn der zweiten
und letzten folge
betrachten wir einige eigenschaften
dieses erstaunlichen gelben metalls dank
seiner beständigkeit befindet sich noch
immer alles je abgebaute gold an der
erdoberfläche wieder und wieder
eingeschmolzen
ein ring in einem zug in dubai kann gold
enthalten das einst kleopatra getragen
hatte dies ist nur eine facette von gold
gold ist eines der seltensten elemente
der welt die erdkruste besteht nur zu
drei milliarden aus gold stellen wir uns
einen berg mit einer milliarde modems
vor von denen nur drei aus gold sind
gold ist 19 mal schwerer als wasser und
doppelt so schwer wie blei
über 90 prozent der oberirdischen gold
vorkommen wurden seit beginn des
kalifornischen goldrausch abgebaut würde
man den gesamten goldbestand der erde in
einen draht mit einer dicke von einem
millimeter ziehen könnte man diesen 300
mal um die erde wickeln
im laufe der geschichte hat der mensch
188.000 tonnen gold abgebaut
mit dieser menge könnte man zwei
olympische schwimmbecken aus gießen
doch es gibt nicht nur barren den
tresoren und ringe an fingern gold ist
vielseitig neben finanziellem und
symbolischem wert findet gold auch in
elektronik bei kabeln in zahnheilkunde
und medizin beim strahlenschutz und beim
tönen von glas verwendung aus einer
tonne computern kann man mehr gold
gewinnen als aus 17 tonnen golderz
selbst der menschliche körper enthält
0,2 milligramm gold das meiste davon im
blut
[Musik]
die mit abstand größten goldvorräte
lagern in den hochsicherheitstresoren
der zentralbanken die zehn größten
zentralbanken der welt lagerten 2016
etwa 23.000 tonnen gold der iwf noch
einmal 2000 tonnen das entspricht etwa
zwölf prozent des jemals geförderten
goldes dank seiner erstaunlichen
eigenschaften als element bot gold
jahrtausendelang einen beständigen
wertspeicher gleichwohl bemängelten
viele kritiker aufgrund dieser
eigenschaften
es wäre eine langweilige wertanlage mit
nur geringem gewinnpotenzial
das verkennt jedoch völlig den sinn des
goldes im portfolio
denn auch wenn es seltsam anmutet ist
die langweiligkeit des goldes seine
attraktive eigenschaft kritiker
bemängeln die langweilige rendite weil
sie gold als investition sehen gold soll
gar keine rendite bieten es ist keine
investition gold bietet keine rendite
weil es risikofrei ist ohne risiko gibt
es auch keine rendite eine banknote
bildet keine rendite wenn man sie nicht
bei einer bank ein zahlt dann ist sie
keine banknote mehr sondern die haftung
der bank während man selbst gläubiger
der bank wird und das risiko eingeht
dass sie nicht zahlt das größte risiko
dass gold vermeidet und andere währungen
zu hauf haben sind dauerhafte störungen
anders gesagt das risiko dauerhaften
wertverlustes der goldpreis mag steigen
oder sinken aber das gold bleibt
bestehen
sie sind gold ist eine hervorragende
absicherung bei steigender inflation
die bei deflation funktioniert es auch
aber man sollte dabei mehr auf die
kaufkraft als auf die preise in gold um
zehn prozent fällt und aktien um 70
prozent ist es immer noch ziemlich gut
schließlich hat man seine kaufkraft
dabei massiv erhöht wenn man sich
ansieht unter welchen bedingungen gold
sich besonders gut
macht das sind es oft wenn auch nicht
immer katastrophen so ein ich würde also
zustimmen
die rendite von gold ist langweilig
langweilig im sinne von 35 dollar 1971
und etwa 1250 dollar heute wenn ich die
rendite anderer wertanlagen ohne
absicherung sehe will ich mehr von
dieser langeweile
für viele ist gold nur ein preis auf
einem fernseher oder computer bildschirm
oft diene diese fluktuationen als
einziges maß ob eine investition in gold
ein erfolg oder ein fehlschlag war
ist diese fixierung auf den preis
wirklich der richtige ansatz
und wenn nicht was dann
man blickt nur auf den preis von gold
sowie man immer nur auf den preis blickt
eine folge der finanziell easy rung man
kennt den preis aller dinge aber nicht
ehren wert infolge der finanzierung
leben wir in einer zeit in der märkte
alles bepreist also verfolgt man die
preise aller dinge und bemisst seinen
wert anhand der ausgewiesenen anzahl an
toller wer nur darauf achten wie viel
geld man hat sollte nach japan gehen
die haben 100 mal so viel geld wie wir
denn der japanische yen hat einen
wechselkurs von etwa 100 zu 1 wer ein
millionär sein will kann das dort viel
schneller erreichen
viele die in gold investieren regen sich
auf dass der preis steigt oder sinkt sie
glauben sie hätten zur falschen zeit
investiert das ist natürlich die falsche
sichtweise den gold ist seit
jahrtausenden geld weil es so stabil ist
tatsächlich schwankt der preis des
dollars gemessen in gold nicht umgekehrt
man kann natürlich viel geld mit
spekulationen verdienen fiat währungen
steigen gelegentlich auch im wert selbst
während der hyperinflation in der
weimarer republik gab es riesige wert
springe und wer in gold angelegt hatte
war sicher der markt würde alles
bereinigen
das sehen wir auch heute auf dem
goldmarkt nach der fokus sollte also
nicht auf dem goldpreis liegen sondern
darauf sein vermögen zu bewahren
gold bewahrt kaufkraft vergrößert sie
sogar auf lange sicht
man sollte sich auf einem sinkenden
schiff wie dem us dollar heute nicht
allzu bequem machen wenn man die
strukturen des heutigen goldmarkt es
nicht wirklich versteht ist der reine
fokus auf den preis von gold ein irrweg
besonders sei 2013 beobachten wir
beachtliche ströme physische
verlagerungen vom westen aus grob gesagt
in den osten vor allem nach china
diese physische verlagerung hat den
preis nicht erhöht sondern gesenkt seit
2013 hat sich der preis trotz der
physischen verlagerung nicht bewegt
wer sich nur auf den preis konzentriert
übersieht dabei also einen großen teil
des informations gefüges über das
tatsächliche geschehen viele versteifen
sich auf den goldpreis doch der
goldpreis und der preis von gold sind
zwei verschiedene dinge
der preis von gold beschreibt die kosten
des besitzers eine münze und eines
barrens ist also der preis des metalls
an sich der goldpreis hingegen ist
lediglich eine bezugsgröße anhand derer
tagtäglich auf der ganzen welt der preis
von papiergold produkten festgelegt wird
was aber ist papiergold warum ist der
aufstieg dieser derivat verträge
möglicherweise so gefährlich sind
verträge
darum sage ich papier verschiedenartige
vertragsverhältnisse die einem teilhabe
am goldpreis ermöglichen
nicht jedoch tatsächlich ist gold
verschaffen es gibt viele davon zum
beispiel gold-futures an der comex der
börse von allen voran steht der gold etf
tld nehmen wir also die als beispiel
ich kaufe kein gold auch wenn viele das
glauben ich kaufe aktienanteile an der
new yorker börse diese anteile
ermöglichen preis teilhabe
wenn ich sie verkaufe landen sie nicht
wieder im tresor sondern ich verkaufe
sie an einen willigen abnehmer
beschreibt gold das in form von
zertifikaten gehandelt wird
ein beispiel dafür wäre der etf gld die
eta feingold derivat das an der new
yorker börse gehandelt wird
für aigner ist es ausreichend man kann
schließlich nicht bei der abholung
überfallen werden und muss es nicht im
garten vergraben
es ist aber kein physisches gold leute
die dem finanzsystem misstrauen sind mit
derivaten aber nicht zufrieden
sie wollen etwas greifbares
in fest man könnte sagen papiergold
entspricht dem futures-markt der futures
markt ist riesig
wenn man sich das gold als absicherung
kaufen will
zum schutz vor finanziellen katastrophen
oder dergleichen kommt man aus meiner
sicht nicht umhin physisches gold zu
kaufen
man will nicht mit einem mittelsmann
arbeiten man braucht das tatsächliche
spekulieren will kann das mit papiergold
tun aber es ist einfach nicht das wahre
ob man einen schriftlichen vertrag mit
besitzanspruch oder tatsächlich gold in
der hand hat macht einen deutlich
größeren unterschied als man annehmen
könnte der besitzanspruch physischen
goldes aufgrund schriftlicher verträge
wird im westen völlig anders
wahrgenommen als im osten
durch zahlreiche inflationen und
regierungen die ihre währungen entwerten
erlangte gold dort ein deutlich anderes
anziehen
gold ist dort kulturell viel fester
verankert würde ich so einen vortrag vor
jungen frauen aus südostasien halten
wenn sie mich auslachen und sagen wir
haben hier seit 1500 jahren erfahrung
mit gehalten
mit gut wir wissen schon viel länger als
ihr dass die regierung nicht unser
freund ist und dass wir ein tausch
medium brauchen das auch ein
wertspeicher ist ich vermute dass
kulturen mit geringerem sozialen
vertrauen eine größere affinität zu gold
haben da man aufgrund des goldes nicht
so sehr auf bloßes vertrauen bauen
musste
im westen haben wir seit etwa 100 jahren
vertrauenswürdige regierungen mit
begrenzter macht der osten hatte weniger
glück mit der beschränkung von
regierungen damit dem volk das recht auf
geld und eigentum gewährt wäre
darum ist es nachvollziehbar dass die
bevölkerung in östlicher staaten ihren
regierungen weniger vertrauen
die idee das gold auch geld ist
verschwand im osten also nie in gleichem
maße wie im westen wohl auch daher dass
niemand den fiat währungen dieser
regierungen vertraute auch im westen
wurde uns das letztendlich wieder
bewusst aber es ist dennoch ein
wichtiger unterschied
man sollte hierbei nicht einfach boston
und west nord erscheinen
ich halte es viel mehr für sinnvoll
zwischen traditionell stabilen und
traditionell instabilen staaten zu
unterscheiden
in singapur zum beispiel oder hongkong
ist für die ältere generation nach wie
vor gold
das einzige wahre geld ein stückchen
sicherheit und so weiter für die jungen
aber nicht
sie vertrauen dem geld ihrer regierung
in den ärmeren staaten gilt das weniger
die alten haben ihrer währung nie
vertraut im internet in indonesien oder
indien haben sie damit nebenbei bemerkt
doch recht an auch die jungen sind
misstrauisch im vergleich zu den
industrienationen funktioniert das für
sie auch überraschend gut
die unterschiede in der wahrnehmung von
gold im osten verglichen mit der
wahrnehmung im westen haben
wahrscheinlich geschichtliche
hintergründe für westliche welt
insbesondere in den usa ist es einfach
sehr lange her dass die vereinigten
staaten eine währungskrise oder
staatliche insolvenz hatten
das ist zum teil sicher auch eine folge
der außergewöhnlich privilegierten
situation seit der schließung des gold
fensters 1971 für östliche bevölkerungen
liegen persönliche erfahrungen mit
währungskrisen und geldentwertung viel
weniger weit zurück daher ist man im
osten skeptischer als im westen
man hat dort eben tatsächlich die
erfahrung gemacht dass gold vor
währungsabwertung schützt zudem muss man
im westen auch bedenken was übrigens den
politischen entscheidungsträgern und
finanzexperten im westen hoch
anzurechnen ist dass es hier und vor
allem in den usa viel besser verstanden
wurde finanzmarkt preise zu verwalten
es gibt ein ehemals geheimes dokument
von 1974 aus der us botschaft in london
in dem festgestellt wurde dass die
einrichtung eines umfassenden marktes
für gold futures einen großen beitrag
für den goldpreis leisten könnte wodurch
der bedarf nach physischem gold in den
usa wie gewünscht sinken würde
so steht es geschrieben schwarz auf weiß
offizielle us geschichte ich komme
gerade von einer konferenz in singapur
da ist der preis den leuten egal
sie häufen stetig weiter gold an sie
sehen es als währung geld sie kümmern
sich nicht um die preise sie wollen nur
gold gesetzen viel gold im westen
hingegen kaufen wir sehr prozyklisch
wenn man die nachfrage von ets verfolgt
steigt diese nachfrage immer sobald die
preise steigen
ich würde sagen es ist dynamischer wenn
ich wiederum die wahrnehmung von gold
beispielsweise in meiner heimat
österreich oder deutschland vergleiche
sehe ich darin unsere finanzielle dna
wir haben wegen unserer großeltern die
alles verloren haben immer noch die
hyperinflation im kopf während die usa
immer noch von der weltwirtschaftskrise
und der deflation traumatisiert sind
das erklärt zum teil wohl auch warum
unsere zentralbanken sich so
unterschiedlich verhalten
in china wurde dieses jahrhundert viel
gold gekauft vor zwölf jahren hatten sie
fast keines aber heute kaufen sie so
viel wie jährlich insgesamt gefördert
wird wenn nicht sogar mehr
niemand weiß wie viel es in china gibt
wahrscheinlich haben sie 20.000 tonnen
gold wir wissen nicht wie die verteilung
zwischen staatlichem und privatem
goldbesitz ist aber ich bin sicher
niemand hat mehr gold als sie
seit der einführung von gold futures
1972 wurde papiergold im westen immer
beliebter
dank termin verträgen und dem folgenden
boom der e t s gibt es viele
möglichkeiten ohne tatsächlichen
goldbesitz einen schriftlichen anspruch
darauf zu haben
papiergold findet man jedoch nicht nur
bei privaten investoren
im laufe der zeit tauschten selbst
westliche zentralbanken ihr physisches
gold gegen schriftliche verträge oder
zusagen in form von leasingverträgen mit
sogenannten gold banken
warum aber ziehen die investoren im
westen etf dem physischen gold vor
und wie könnte ihnen das noch zum
verhängnis werden
die etf werden nicht nur bei gold
bevorzugt es gibt eine gewaltige
trendwende von aktiven zu passiven
anlagestrategien
das liegt wohl auch daran dass in diesem
zeitalter der finanzierung größere
marktkapitalisierung unternehmen
erfolgreicher sind als kleinere
unternehmen da sie alleine schon
aufgrund ihres handelsvolumens bessere
konditionen und zinsen bekommen was die
im wettbewerb schadet eine folge der
finanzierung des kredit basierten
oligarchischen systems das wir jetzt
haben
vor diesem hintergrund sind etf einfach
und günstig sie sind aktien insbesondere
in bezug auf gold muss man auch die
struktur dieser aufsteigenden branche
beachten
in der die meisten wenn nicht sogar alle
manager ein mandat haben ein regelwerk
das bestimmt was sie kaufen können und
was nicht
fast alle mandate gestatten den kauf von
dividendenpapieren wenige manager können
jedoch waren handeln insbesondere
physische güter für den kauf physischer
waren muss man in gremien belege
vorlegen und dergleichen
wogegen man einen etf welcher ja
letztendlich nur eine aktie ist ohne
probleme jederzeit kaufen kann
etf sind eine lösung für ein problem das
es nicht gibt es heißt immer es sei
alles so einfach
man könne sie mit einem investment konto
handeln
alles schön und gut letztlich könnte die
investmentbank ganz einfach wenn sie
eine provision von den etf anbietern
bekommen wollte was sie wahrscheinlich
ohne ihn tut könnten wir ihr
geschäftspartner sein und physisches
gold handeln anstatt uns über ets
letztlich aktien die mit gold verbunden
sind zu kaufen
es könnte eben auch physisches gold sein
das wäre nicht allzu schwierig da müsste
einfach nur im internet suchen in fünf
minuten auf google eine firma wie unsere
finden ein paar formulare ausfüllen
das wäre schon alles wie überhaupt nicht
schwierig wenn man gold besitzt um auf
den preis zu spekulieren sind etf wohl
das richtige
nutzt man gold hingegen als versicherung
oder als deckungs geschäft buchstäblich
um sich gegenüber chaotischen störungen
des finanzsystems in deckung zu beginn
ist er gibt es natürlich keinerlei sinn
sie nur innerhalb des finanzsystems zu
besitzen
im fall von glg zum beispiel liegt die
quote bei in etwa zehn prozent das heißt
für 100 tatsächliche ziel die aktien
sind 110 auf dem markt zehn davon sind
geliehene leerverkäufen
es gibt also mehr aktien als es geben
sollte was auf dem normalen markt kein
problem ist aber genau das darstellt
wogegen man sich mit gold absichern will
all diese risiken bei etf stehen in
einem direkten verhältnis mit krisen von
kapitalmärkten finanzinstitutionen und
den geld systemen wegen derer man eben
gold besitzen will warum sollte man das
vermischen
warum das risiko schultern wenn man dann
doch nicht
zahlt wird wenn es soweit ist
da es den menschen seit jeher fasziniert
ranken sich viele verschwörungs mythen
um gold bei denen es zum beispiel um
preisdruck und manipulation geht
das ist wenig überraschend denn wenn es
um geld geht sind betrüger niemals weit
gefälschte goldbarren tauchen immer
wieder auf zumeist aus vergoldetem
wolfram da es die gleiche dichte wie
gold hat glücklicherweise lässt sich mit
verschiedenen einfachen tests sicher
klären ob ein waren echt ist oder nicht
gold ist einzigartig bei den wichtigsten
fragen zur goldpreis manipulation geht
es jedoch um breitere themen auf
oberster ebene
die frage der manipulation ist sehr
beliebt und wird natürlich gerne
diskutiert wer sich auch nur ein wenig
mit der historischen faktenlage
auseinandersetzt weiß woher der wind
weht
es ist nun wirklich kein geheimnis
hinter dem londoner gold pool gab es und
das war ein ganz offener versuch gold
auf kreisebene zu kontrollieren es war
eindeutig im interesse der zentralbanken
insbesondere in unserem geldsystem ob
dieses nun funktioniert ist hier
nebensache
es war in ihrem interesse risikofreie
zinserträge zu kontrollieren würde man
den goldpreis beeinflussen vor allem
gold ist das wechselseitige vertrauen
der zentralbahn zentralbanken besitzen
das meiste gold der erde etwa 68 prozent
ihrer reserven sind gold würden sie ihn
drücken wollen
tun sie es weiß ich nicht aber es geht
ums geld also im zweifelsfall
wahrscheinlich schon
andere sind davon überzeugt nicht nur
davon dass der goldpreis beeinflusst
wird sondern auch darüber wer dahinter
steckt natürlich ist der goldpreis
manipuliert ich rede dabei aber nicht
von einer düsteren verschwörung ich
glaube nicht dass janet yellen morgens
aufwacht und über gold saniert ich
glaube ja dass sie gar nichts über gold
weiß sie ist eine würdige links liberale
ökonomen die die philips kurve verehrt
und ich glaube nicht dass sie hinter
einer verschwörung steckt um den
goldpreis zu drücken
aber er wird manipuliert ich habe mich
mit experten unterhalten
darunter auch ein doktor der statistik
wohlgemerkt kein ökonom sondern
statistiker der für einen der größten
hedgefonds der welt arbeitet er hat sich
die entwicklung der gold futures am
comics über zehn jahre angesehen präzise
öffentliche aufzeichnung
er sagte die daten ließen sich nur durch
manipulation erklären sie werden auf
keinen fall durch normale marktkräfte
zustande gekommen
er bemerkte vor allem dass der goldpreis
bei der letzten preisänderung des
handelstages einbrach nur um am beginn
des nächsten tages nach oben zu schießen
er meinte das wäre der einfachste handel
der welt man muss nur nach kurzschluss
kaufen und am nächsten morgen direkt
verkaufen
schon macht man langsam aber stetig
gewinnen wer aber weiß wie offene märkte
funktionieren weiß auch das langsame
stetige gewinne unmöglich sind
das sagte auch bernie madoff er sagte
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass der preis
über zehn jahre natürlich zum
kurzschluss sinkt und am morgen steigt
läge bei null
das sind nicht nur indizien es ist wie
täter-dna man erwischt niemanden in
flagranti
aber man hat dna-beweise wer es war nach
dieser kontrolle strebten regierungen
schon immer und überall
denn es geht um die nationale sicherheit
das war auch bei den römern schon so den
wert der währung zu verwalten ist
überlebenswichtig das wird besonders
deutlich wenn es eine regierung nicht
allzu gut gelingt leider ist das bei den
meisten regierungen früher oder später
der fall damit die manipulation fand
also ganz offen statt durch die
einrichtung des derivatemarktes der eine
nachfrage auffing umsonst im physischen
gold galt darum ging es
und das verstehen viele marktteilnehmer
nicht wirklich man findet es aber
schwarz auf weiß in den archiv
wenn man sich den goldhandel ansieht wie
er abstürzt wenn jemand nachts um 2 uhr
new yorker 23 milliarden dollar an
fiktiven werten ab stößt dann kann ich
nach 22 jahren an der wallstreet sagen
dass sich ein händler auf der
käuferseite bald einen neuen job suchen
dürfte wenn er das regelmäßig macht es
geht ihnen dabei offensichtlich nicht um
gekonnte handels ausführung
darum geht s nicht letzten endes ist es
prinzipiell währungsinterventionen wer
steckt dahinter
ursprünglich hatte die us regierung ein
starkes interesse daran die wahrnehmung
des dollars mit hilfe von gold zu längst
es gibt ein bekanntes zitat von eddie
george aus den spielen 1990 ern
er war funktioniert bei der bank of
england er sagte wir blickten in den
abgrund
würde der goldpreis weiter steigen viele
ihm ein großes handelshaus nach dem
anderen zum opfer das war ein zeichen
dafür dass die banken in die gold
finanzierung eingestiegen waren wodurch
sie im falle einer ernsthaften nachfrage
von gold in ernsthafte existenznöte
geraten wären ja ich denke der goldpreis
ist manipuliert manipulierte auf
verschiedene art und weise
natürlich gibt es besagt die
koordinierte pr-kampagne der
zentralbanken gegen das gold der
goldpreis zu schwächen ist insbesondere
im interesse der zentral und
nationalbanken man will mit der extrem
starkem auftreten verhindern dass gold
mit dem goldpreis letztlich wieder als
leitwährung eingeführt wird
daher sehen wir auch die ständige
schlechte presse gegenüber der
goldindustrie die spezielle manipulation
des goldpreises halte ich wohl auch für
wahrscheinlich leider können wir das
nicht genau wissen denn die
zentralbanken sind sehr undurchsichtig
wenn es um ihre goldbestände und
insbesondere ihre swap positionen bei
gold geht
ich halte es für wahrscheinlich und zwar
weil sie andere märkte schon seit langem
manipulieren früher hielten sich
hedgefonds aus geldgeschäften raus es
gab ein paar spezialisten dabei an sich
handelten sie aktien
dann hätten sie sich ans gold für sie
ist es nur ein weiteres gut kaffeebohne
in sojabohnen holz ganz egal es sind
handelsware wenn sie gold leer verkaufen
wollen machen die einen vertrag mit
goldman sachs und fertig das macht
manipulation ganz einfach man kann den
goldmarkt einfach teched in futures
markt manipulieren
kürzlich erst vor ein paar wochen
verkaufte jemand papiergold gleichwertig
zu 60 tonnen gold um das klar zu machen
sie haben nicht 60 tonnen gold verkauft
sondern futures verträge im wert von 60
tonnen gold ich kann auch 60 tonnen
papier gold mit einem anruf bei einem
makler verkaufen
ich brauche dafür nur ein makler konnte
und einem marsch aber das drückte den
preis innerhalb von minuten um 20 oder
30 dollar pro unze
wenn ich also auf der die warte seite
leer verkaufen
und hier mein gold abstoße sinkt der
preis und ich mache hier gewinnen oder
'ich plane langfristig und treibe den
preis in den keller
kaufe wieder und reihte die welle nach
oben
es überrascht nicht dass hedgefonds und
händler an gold banken den goldpreis
verschieben um gewinn zu machen
gold bleibt ein strategischer wert und
grundlage der finanzen vieler staaten
dennoch gibt es marktteilnehmer viel
größer als hedge fonds die kein
interesse an profit haben sondern beim
drücken des goldpreises viel größere
ziele verfolgen
die entscheidende frage ist wer tut es
und warum ich würde auch interessieren
warum überwachungsbehörden wie die
commodity futures trading commission
nicht einschreiten
es könnte sein dass china dahinter
steckt und es außerhalb unseres rechts
bereichs liegt keine us behörde würde
chinesische aktivitäten auf unserem
markt untersuchen
china ist einfach zu wichtig sie sind
ein unbeweglicher souveräner staat mit
dem man sich aus millionen
diplomatischer und sicherheitstechnische
gründe auf dieser ebene nicht anlegen
will
china ist mein hauptverdächtiger man
sollte meinen sie haben all das gold
warum wollen sie den preis drücken weil
sie immer noch einkaufen
am ende wollen sie dass sich der preis
so entwickelt wie es kommen wird
10.000 dollar pro unze oder mehr aber
noch nicht denn sie kaufen noch
schließen zu den usa auf sie haben
tausende tonnen gold gekauft aber es
fehlen noch tausende tonnen mehr um die
usa beim verhältnis von
bruttoinlandsprodukt zu gold einzuholen
ob sie nun ihre 8000 tonnen bekommen
oder das verhältnis erreichen
sie müssen die usa so oder so noch
einmal nicht alle veteranen des
goldmarktes sind überzeugt dass der
goldpreis manipuliert wird
ihre argumentation der staatlich
finanzierten preisdrückerei weit
hergeholt ist einfach nachzuvollziehen
und schwer zu widerlegen alle
finanzmärkte werden immer wieder
manipuliert
anders als viele meiner kollegen sehe
ich oft preismanipulationen nach oben
wenn es einfacher ist langfristige
manipulation erfordert eine verschwörung
in einem ausmaß dass ich für unmöglich
halte wer glaubt die us-regierung die
trilaterale kommission und die jüdische
weltverschwörung könnten sich
zusammenrotten und drei jahrzehnte lang
den goldpreis manipulieren vergisst
dabei dass die us-regierung nicht einmal
schulbildung oder postzustellung auf die
reihe bekommt sie hat die kriege gegen
drogen und armut verloren den krieg in
vietnam und den in afghanistan
wie könnten sie also eine umfangreiche
manipulation auf die beine stellen wenn
sie noch nicht einmal ihre eigenen
feldzüge bewältigen können früher oder
später manipulieren die meisten
regierungen den goldpreis um ihre macht
zu erhalten
es ist also möglich mir hat aber noch
niemand belastbare beweise gezeigt es
ist normal dass gold bei kreditblasen
hinterher hängt dafür braucht es keine
preis drücken durchziehen ist die
zentralbanken das ist bei kreditblasen
ebenso alles steigt im wert relativ zu
gold und wenn die blase platzt bricht
alles wieder ein
das ist ganz natürlich das sah man auch
in den letzten 40 jahren der nennen
preis von gold ist von 2000 bis 2008
gestiegen im vergleich mit öl und
anderen gütern jedoch gesunken
das machte sich also sehr schlecht
tatsächlich stand gold aber fantastisch
da als die blase platzte
sowohl beim endpreis als auch beim
realwert dann erschuf banecki eine noch
größere blase und auch hier ging es dem
gold natürlich wieder schlecht hat aber
die fed den preis nach unten manipuliert
schon möglich aber diese theorie hilft
uns nicht weiter
warum ist die goldpreis drücken jedoch
so wichtig was würde passieren wenn sie
aufgedeckt und gestoppt würde im januar
2018 wurde zuletzt eine gruppe von
händlern die für gold banken arbeiteten
dafür belangt dass sie den
edelmetallmarkt manipulieren wollten
kein schema das mal wieder und wieder
sieht
diese nachgewiesene preismanipulation am
goldmarkt hatte jedoch wie oft zuvor
keine nennenswerten auswirkungen auf den
preis alle manipulationen des
goldmarktes und preis drücken generell
gelangen irgendwann an ihr ende
die möglichen konsequenzen
letztendlich scheitern alle
manipulationsversuche der londoner gold
pool von 1968 scheiterte als die usa und
der iwf in den 70ern den markt mit 1700
tonnen gold fluteten war der preis in
den 80ern höher denn je
in den späten 90ern drängten wir
großbritannien dazu die hälfte ihres
goldes zu verkaufen
jetzt stecken sie in der klemme in den
2000 dann war die schweiz dran die wir
zum verkauf von 2.000 tonnen drängten
jetzt aber haben wir niemanden mehr der
sein gold verkaufen will
irgendwann werden die eigner von
papiergold erkennen dass sie es nie
ausbezahlt bekommen werden weil der
gegenwert in gold nicht existiert dann
sitzen sie da mit nichts als einem stück
papier
ob nun von komik seiner gold bank oder
einem anderen goldhändler und machen
pleite wenn dann also kein gold mehr
verfügbar ist und der preis nach oben
springt wird es schwierig gold zu kaufen
die geschichte lehrt uns dass der markt
stärker ist als die regierungen wenn die
aktuelle blase platzt können sie noch so
sehr versuchen es zu manipulieren
gold wird stets allen
manipulationsversuchen widerstehen neben
verschwörungstheorien und manipulations
erzählungen bietet die geschichte des
goldes viele anschauliche beispiele für
seinen stellenwert die bedeutsamkeit
seines schutzes und die mitunter
tödlichen bemühungen der menschen das zu
besetzen
als die wehrmacht sich 1939 gegen
großbritannien formierte verpflichtete
die britische regierung die bewohner ihr
gold vermögen bei der königlichen
schatzkammer anzumelden
am siebten oktober 1939 machte sich die
lms emerald von clamav auf nach halifax
in nova scotia im frachtraum befand sich
gold im wert von vielen millionen pfund
um kriegsgerät von den usa zu erwerben
als der krieg ein jahr später für die
alliierten schlecht lief und der
nordatlantik peter umkämpft war
beschlagnahmte premierminister winston
churchill mit seinen notstands rechten
das im vorjahr angemeldete goldmann
brachte es heimlich zum hafen von green
rock und gutes auf die ages emerald die
in richtung kanada in see stach würde
großbritannien von den nazis überrannt
hätte man immer noch die mittel um
weiter zu kämpfen
eine woche später erfolgte ein weiterer
konvoi mit gold im wert von damals 1,7
milliarden dollar was heute einen wert
von 29 milliarden dollar entsprechen
insgesamt brachte man gold im wert von
30 milliarden heutigen dollar
tausende meilen durch die tückische sie
vorbei an lauen den u booten und verlor
nicht eine unze die größte und wohl
riskanteste reichtums verlagerung der
weltgeschichte geschichten wie die
britische gold evakuierung des zweiten
weltkriegs sind gut dokumentiert
es gibt jedoch auch legenden von
verschwundenen schätzen die schatzjäger
seit anbeginn der zeit in ihren bann
ziehen
teile davon handelt von einem
berüchtigten japanischen general und
einem versteckten goldschatz im wert von
milliarden
die legende von yamashita us gold gibt
es seit 70 jahren
bis heute zieht sie schatzsucher aus
aller welt auf die philippinen wo
general tomoyuki yamashita der
berüchtigte tiger von malaria einen
milliardenschweren schatz aus
plünderungen in ganz südostasien
versteckt haben soll
auf ihrem weg durch südostasien
plünderte yamashita us-armee gold aus
banktresoren depots und geschäften
raubgut mit dem japans regierung die
wachsenden kosten des krieges decken
wollte das gold kam aus singapur auf die
philippinen von wo aus es nach japan
weiter sollte der pazifik krieg und der
aufstieg der us marine machte die
verlegung des goldes jedoch unmöglich
also versteckte man es angeblich
irgendwo tief im philippinischen
dschungel
viele von denen die das versteck des
schatzes kranken kamen im krieg um
yamashita selbst wurde 1946 wegen
kriegsverbrechen hingerichtet ohne die
lage des schatzes preiszugeben
in den folgenden 70 jahren suchten
hunderte glücksritter nach yamashita das
gold der schatzsucher rosalie roxas
verklagte in hawaii den ehemaligen
präsidentin der philippinen ferdinand
marcos dieser habe das gold gestohlen
das schild abenteurer aber nicht davon
ab beim philippinischen nationalmuseum
eine schatzsuche lizenz anzufordern
boxers wurde vom gericht der höchste
schadenersatz aller zeiten zugesprochen
40,5 milliarden dollar was im
revisionsprozess allerdings auf 13
millionen dollar gesenkt wurde
boxer starb unter unklaren umständen am
abend vor der verhandlung und erlebte
das ende seiner schatzsuche nicht das
gericht befand roxas habe zwar einen
schatz gefunden nicht jedoch
notwendigerweise den von yamashita wegen
diesem detail machen sich nach wie vor
jede menge möchtegern indiana jones auf
nach manila
die bewegte geschichte des goldes hat
seine bedeutung für den menschen geprägt
steht jedoch im gegensatz zur aktuellen
lage
da die welt sich immer stärker auf
schulden stützt um ihr echtes geld
system aufrechterhalten und den
untergang der welt wie wir sie kennen zu
verhindern
in der ersten folge sahen wir wie der
goldstandard funktionierte und wie
richard nixon ihn am 15
august 1971 abschaffte ist eine rückkehr
zum goldstandard überhaupt möglich was
würde eine rückkehr zur finanziellen
zurückhaltung für unser heutiges
geldsystem bedeuten warum ist das für so
viele ein streitpunkt
es ist ein streitpunkt für die die gerne
schuldenmachen regierungen banken leute
die über ihre verhältnisse leben
für sie ist es ein streitpunkt weil gold
verhindert dass sie mehr ausleihen als
sie zurückzahlen können bei fiat geld
kann man grenzenlos laien und druckt für
die rückzahlung einfach mehr geld
es ist also besser für die die geld
verdienen wenn sie geld produzieren
banken das mindestreserve bankwesen
zentralbanken regierungen die sich lohn
schlachten liefern und die finanzierung
dafür selbst in unbegrenzten mengen
truppen
aber ich glaube es ist für alle anderen
gut gut für sparer gut für jene die eine
altersvorsorge anlegen da das geld
später noch eine ähnliche kaufkraft
haben wird wie zum anlage zeitpunkt die
vorstellung eines goldstandards
widerstrebt manchen schon sehr denn dann
könnten sie nicht mehr immer dann krieg
führen wenn es ihnen passt oder die
staatliche gesundheitsversorgung
jederzeit ausbauen dinge mit denen man
in washington und ebenso anderen ländern
an der macht bleibt
wenn man sich aber die entwicklung des
währungssystems der letzten 30 40 jahre
ansieht haben einzig die usa
außerordentliche privilegien die
struktur des systems erlegt anderen
ländern regeln und grenzen auf die für
die usa lange nicht existierten
darum legt das establishment auch so
eine extreme abneigung gegenüber dem
goldstandard an den tag wenn
zentralbanker über den goldstandard
reden kennen sie nur sehr vage seine
vorzüge
sie sagen die kosten seien zu groß
darunter eben die tatsache dass die fed
und die regierung die wirtschaft nicht
mehr manipulieren könnten mit dem
goldstandard gebe es schreckliche
depressionen und arbeitslosigkeit und
die regierung könnte nichts dagegen tun
die kosten wären zu hoch da die
regierung die preise nicht stabilisieren
könnte das ist natürlich irrsinn
denn die blasen des neunzehnten und des
frühen zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war
nicht folgen des goldstandards sondern
des banksystems
dieses hat intrinsische menge es
erschafft blasen die dann platzen ganz
unabhängig von gold nach dem wechsel vom
gold zum dollar standard sehen wir immer
noch blasen schlimmere als jemals zuvor
die stabilisierung erzeugt also die
probleme in der weltwirtschaftskrise der
1930 er jahre schrieb hayek dass die
stabilisierung der 20er jahre das
problem erschaffen hatte
da die preise auf zu hohem niveau
gehalten wurden es war nicht das gold
oder der goldstandard der die blasen
erschuf es war das banksystem es ist
schon befremdlich wie ben bernanke immer
wieder dem gold die schuld für die
probleme der banken gab die er
verwaltete und die jetzt allen verwaltet
es gibt nicht genug geld um unsere
situation zu stützen ohne den goldpreis
anzupassen
es wurden dafür einmal 35.000 dollar pro
unze genannt das argument war das würde
behörden instituten und besonders
zentral banken zwingen sich bei der
quantitativen lockerung zuzüge ich denke
ein neuer ausgleich wird kommen manche
reden vom neustart wie man es auch nennt
es kommt in den nächsten paar jahren
dann entsteht etwas neues möglicherweise
mit verbindungen zu gold und wer weiß
etwas anderen zentralbanken müssen dann
ein neues bezugssystem finden das immun
gegen quantitative lockerung ist gold
kann man nicht trocken
ein barbarisches relikt so nannte john
maynard keynes einst das älteste tausch
medium der menschheit so die gold bei
einem neustart seine position als
grundpfeiler des modernen finanzsystems
behalten
der aufstieg von crypto währungen wie
dem bitcoin in den letzten jahren heizte
die diskussionen über die zukunft des
geldsystems und die rolle des goldes neu
an
manche glauben crypto währungen würden
gold ablösen
wahrscheinlicher ist es jedoch dass es
keinen klaren sieger geben wird glaube
ich dass es platz für einen algorithmus
als tausch medium gibt der zudem
vertrauen überflüssig macht wenn er
direkt und diskret ist wie bitkom will
ich mein gesamtes erspartes in einer
währung anliegen
deren einziger wert ein algorithmus ist
[Musik]
als währungs konsument will ich viele
währungen
ich will anhand ihres nutzens zum
jeweiligen zeitpunkt entscheiden was
meiner karriere meinem leben und dem
meiner familie dienlich ist
bitcoin und gold sind konkurrierende
glaubenssysteme das gute an crypto
währungen ist dass sie niemand besitzt
es ist eine demokratische vereinbarung
durch den dezentralen blogs agent in
jeder hat man kauft immer nur einen teil
der block c sie ist also immun gegen
quantitative lockerung
sie hat eine disziplin in das system
eingebaut leider werden sie nicht als
tausch medium genutzt und die behörden
mögen sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht sie
fechten schließlich den stellenwert
unseres bargeld gold ist das andere
glaubenssystem warum kostet das 31.000
und wer sagt dass die antwort ist und
die 31.000 wollen sind hier nur ein
beispiel dass es hunderttausende gibt
die knapp unter diesem preis kaufen und
knapp darüber verkaufen wollen
der preis kommt also in folge des
immensen austausches zwischen käufern
und verkäufern zustande
die politik kann die wahrnehmung
verändern und die verteilung verschieben
der preis wird also durch die schiere
masse derer legitimiert die mit ihm
handeln
so etwas werden regierungen er nicht ein
[Musik]
ich sehe also nur eine möglichkeit wie
gold wieder unser währungssystem
durchdringen kann
bei crypto währungen ist das bereits
besonders faszinierend ist eine art
markt getriebene wiedereinführung genau
das bieten crypto währungen schließlich
wir brauchen keine zentralbank mehr um
währungen international abzuwickeln
brauchen keine massiven bank
institutionen mehr um einen handel
abzuschließen
wir brauchen sie nicht mehr das geht
heute über das smartphone mit crypto
währungen
ich bin davon überzeugt dass eine viel
effizientere währung nur auf ihren
großen auftritt wartet auf basis der
krypto währungen auf unseren smartphones
mit der man weltweit handeln kann ohne
gebühren und der letzte eintrag wird auf
gold in einem tresor in singapur oder in
der schweiz basieren wo es sicher ist
und regierungen es nicht stehlen kann
und so gesehen würde dieses
währungssystem auf gold in einem tresor
basieren sie ein gold ausbaustandard mal
so etwas sehe ich kommen
es ist einfach spannend spannend was
crypto währungen zu bieten haben
das wird nicht nur die welt des goldes
sondern die ganze weltwirtschaft
betreffen
denn die flächendeckende einführung
einer krypta währung auf gold basis
würde das vertrauen der leute genießen
das würde viel verändern
[Musik]
die aktuelle entwicklung finde ich
fantastisch
erstens redet man endlich wieder darüber
was geld ist diese themen sind den
leuten wichtig sie recherchieren
streiten und diskutieren
auf twitter facebook oder wo auch immer
das ist großartig
wir brauchen wettbewerb bei den
währungen derzeit gibt es viele ice ii
aus
als ich zum ersten mal von indischen
offerings hörte viel dich das für einen
witz es klang wie die erstplatzierungen
damals natürlich sind 95 prozent davon
müll und verschwinden nach einiges zwei
jahren wieder aber der bitcoin ist dem
gold sehr ähnlich er hat ein ähnliches
verhältnis und die inflationsrate ist ja
ohnehin gegeben
es gibt so viel bewegung in diesem
bereich man trifft so viele brillante
junge leute die überall chancen sehen
auf konferenzen in der finanzindustrie
geht es ständig und compliance
risikomanagement um neue gesetze
unglaublich viel verwaltungsaufwand
redet man dann mit jungen entwicklern im
krippenbereich sie in die nur chancen
sie sind voller begeisterung es gibt so
viel innovation
ich liebe das das wird viele branchen
insbesondere das bankwesen aufrütteln
allerdings für gold sehe ich es nicht
als konkurrenz denn viele die den
chipcount genau verstehen sagen mir
immer wieder dass das gold nicht in
gefahr seien total morris sagte einmal
der bitcoins elektronisches gold es gibt
viele ähnlichkeiten
man müsste crypto währungen und gold
kombinieren und in dem bereich gibt es
aktuell viele projekte so wird wohl die
zukunft aussehen
und darauf freue ich mich schon in einer
welt die sich dem reibungslosen bezahlen
immer mehr nähert
können crypto währungen und die blogs
chain an sich kostenprobleme
zahlungsverzögerungen und dergleichen
lösen ich glaube eine geldeinheit die
überall verwendung findet ist
unausweichlich
was wird passieren wenn man es richtig
ausarbeitet dem start wird diese lösung
nicht so sehr gefallen wollen aber das
gold wird auch wieder das geld des
volkes sein und nicht das geld des
staates und der unternehmen so bald sein
wird ersichtlich wird sobald man sich
wieder erinnert was gold schon immer war
und was es wieder sein kann wird dir
eine anhäufung größerer beträge
uninteressant die kripo branche wird
wohl versuchen den handel von gold und
silber den die blogs chain zu
integrieren aktuell müssen crypto wie
runge noch die feuerprobe einer
finanzkrise bestehen
gold ist hingegen der eine vermögenswert
der alle krisen der weltgeschichte
überlegt hat 2008 fiel der goldpreis
anfangs überraschend
tatsächlich bot das gold jedoch einem
zahlungsunfähigen marktliquidität als
sich die märkte durch quantitative
lockerung stabilisierten schoss der
goldpreis nach oben
doch welche rolle wird gold in der
nächsten finanzkrise spielen ich halte
es für schwierig vorauszusagen was genau
dem gold passieren wird und wie es
passieren wird
fest steht aber dass gold sich umgekehrt
proportional zum vertrauen in das
finanzsystem verhält das gold unabhängig
von regierungen und dem finanzwesen ist
dass es selten ist gibt ihm potenziell
gewaltigen wert 2008 wird sich nicht
wiederholen
es wird etwas anderes passieren als 2008
ich glaube dass es anders sein wird weil
das problem dass sich 2008 niederschlug
die massive übermäßige verschuldung
sich nach oben auf die starts ebene
verlagert hat die krise der
privatverschuldung wird als krise der
staatsverschuldung zurückkehren
das ist ein ganz anderes kaliber mit
ganz anderen parametern vier zeit sagen
mir viele dass unser bankwesen viel
sicherer sei da die verschuldung
niedriger sei und es weniger
weiterverwendung gebe seien aber die
währung in der sie alles bemessen könnte
uhr plötzlich über nacht völlig
entwertet werden auf ganz andere weise
als es 2008 geschah
wir wissen alle worauf das hinausläuft
wir wissen dass diese schulden nicht
begleichen sind wir wissen dass die
ungedeckten verbindlichkeiten nicht mit
echter kaufkraft aufgewogen werden
können
die frage ist also wie wir das lösen es
gibt nur zwei möglichkeiten
inflation oder deflation letzteres in
form von zahlungs einstellungen auf
grund der wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine
situation wie 2008 wieder eintritt ganz
gleich in welcher form genau bleibt gold
eine der wenigen möglichkeiten sich sein
vermögen und seine kaufkraft zu schützen
der mensch ist im gold jedoch nicht nur
finanziell verboten
die vergangenheit ist voll von
persönlichen geschichten die zeigen wie
gold als wertspeicher als schutz vor
enteignung durch inflation und
entwertung seitens der regierung und
stets einlösbare absicherung das leben
derer die es besitzen beeinflusst ich
kenne jemanden der in vietnam aufwuchs
sein vater übersetzer für die us-armee
im vietnamkrieg als die usa abzogen
konnten sie das land nicht mit den
streitkräften verlassen und blieben
zurück dadurch wurden sie opfer der
unterdrückung durch das kommunistische
regime
diese 14 köpfige familie konnte da ein
onkel zahnarzt war über die nächsten
zehn bis zwölf jahre eine gewisse menge
gold anhäufen ende der 1980 er hatten
sie sieben unzen pro person beisammen
mal 14 also über 100 unzen gold mit
denen sie 14 sitze auf einem boot
sicherten das icon mitten in der nacht
verließ am nächsten tag fiel der motor
aus und sie trieben tage lang auf die
mehr bis die malaysische küstenwache sie
abschleppte sie verbrachten zwei jahre
in einem flüchtlingslager
sie gelangten nach singapur wo der vater
bei der us-botschaft belegte dass er
übersetzer für die streitkräfte der
vereinigten staaten gewesen war
wodurch die ganze 14 köpfige familie
visa bekam und in die usa ausreisen
konnte
das hat diesen menschen das leben
gerettet und all das wegen 7 unzen gold
pro person für eine 14 köpfige familie
mir fällt kein besseres beispiel dafür
eine warum gold ein guter plan b ist vor
ein paar jahren redete ich auf einer
hochzeit mit ein paar freunden aus
russland und der ukraine die
ausgewandert waren und nun die
us-staatsbürgerschaft inhalten
sie erzählten von den 1990 er jahren in
russland
die frau berichtete ihr vater wäre der
arzt ihres dorfes in der ukraine gewesen
sie hätten soviel geld auf der bank
gehabt dass sie die reichste familie des
dorfes waren sie hätten sich fünf autos
kaufen können was für das dorf scheinbar
eine menge war dann schlossen die banken
für zwei wochen und als sie ihr geld
abhoben die weiß noch genug um einen
monat davon zu essen
ihr mann hat er eine ähnliche geschichte
er hatte genug geld gespart um ein
motorrad zu kaufen
aber sein vater ließ sie nicht die
banken schlossen für zwei wochen als er
das geld abhob reichte es noch für eine
stange zigaretten so als ich dann sagte
muss ich hier wohl kaum erklären wie war
es den gold errangen die beiden lachten
und sagten wer gold silber oder schmuck
hatte sei fein raus gewesen
ich liebe die geschichten davon wie man
in frankreich das gold nach kanada und
in andere staaten verschwinden ließ als
die wehrmacht einmarschiert eine tolle
geschichte
die sicher einen guten filme kenne sie
ist wirklich super im grunde teilten sie
ihre goldreserven in winzige teile dann
machten sie sich mit eselskarren und
fischerbooten auf ihr gesamtes vermögen
aus dem land zu schaffen
all das bevor die armee letztlich
einmarschierte eine geschichte von
echtem wagemut fantastisch ich kenne
eine geschichte aus der sowjetunion wo
gold natürlich verboten war und man ins
gefängnis kommen könnte wenn man
physisches gold hatte dürfte aber eher
inge haben auch ihre ringe aus gold
es gab einen cleveren kerl der hatte 50
eheringe
er ging alle paar monate oder einmal im
monat auf den markt und hatte wegen der
goldringe enorme kaufkraft
das zeigt meiner meinung nach deutlich
dass man zumindest ein wenig geld
braucht
so elementar ist auch ist war gold
jedoch stets ein komplexes thema das
seit beginn der zivilisation für heftige
debatten sorgte hoffentlich konnten wir
auf dieser reise wenigstens ein bisschen
vermitteln warum gold seit jahrtausenden
geld ist durch welche umstände die unze
über 1000 dollar kostet wie es weltweit
gehandelt wird und welchen stellenwert
es im heutigen finanzsystem hat
ziel war es nicht überzeugungen zu
ändern sondern zu erklären wie ein
klumpen gelbes metall solche faszination
ausüben kann und warum es auch tausende
von jahren nach seiner entdeckung dass
eine weltweit akzeptierte geld ist wir
hoffen dass wir einige geheimnisse des
goldes lüften und seine rolle bei der
verwahrung und dem schutz von vermögen
erklären konnten
ob sie und ich jedoch glauben dass gold
geld ist ist letztlich völlig
bedeutungslos gold hat sich über
jahrtausende als ein stabiler wert
speicher für die menschheit bewährt in
anbetracht der ungewissen zukunft in der
fiat währungen durch steigende
schuldenberge gefährdet sind ist es das
einzige geld das mit sicherheit
fortbestehen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]